nach einem Jahr Krieg Wladimir haben sie
im Februar gesagt es ist schlimm aber
man hat sich daran gewöhnt was heißt das
geht uns Ukraine allen so dass man sich
daran dass man auch in Europa leider an
diesen grauen taten
eine Gewöhnung Gewohnheit weil das
dauert schon beeinhalb Jahren und wer
weiß wie lange das noch dauern wird wir
wissen es wird ein Ende des Krieges
geben irgendwann wir wissen nicht nur
wann und wie das Ende aussehen wird vor
Gott das sehen Sie das auch so man
gewöhnt sich daran ich habe das im März
in Odessa gesehen dann kommt der
Luftalarm und das Leben geht ganz normal
weiter als ob nichts wäre ja definitiv
also es wird niemals zur Normalität
würde ich sagen es ist nicht normal wenn
Frauen mit kleinen Kindern nachts
hochstecken und dann irgendwo in der
U-Bahn steigen müssen das machen
Familien mit kleinen Kindern immer noch
heute auch aber es man gewöhnt sich auf
jeden Fall also man checkt dann das
Handy wenn Luftalarm kommt man schaut
erstmal wo fliegt was los wie viel Zeit
hat man noch kann man vielleicht noch
zwei Stunden schlafen bevor dann die
Raketen am Himmel zu sehen sind
wenn man diese Bilder hier sieht
Vladimir das ist ein gutes Jahr her
deutlich mehr anderthalb Jahre fast wie
was geht hier durch den Kopf wenn sie
diese Bilder heute sehen
das gehört das gehört schon ja in die
Geschichte wie das alles war damals als
die russische mir eine Grenze von der
Stadt
stand und die grandaten
angerichtet hat in erpin bardenker
gestorbenel Butcher
wir waren da auch mit meinem Bruder
gerade als die russische
Streitkräfte haben
diese Städte verlassen
und das die grauen Taten waren ganz klar
zu sehen
es ist nichts mit dem leben was man so
sie gesehen hat dann gehört hat im
freien Welt
es hat ein schrecklichen Gesicht Krieg
hat ein Schrecken Gesicht sie sind
unfassbar vielleicht gewesen Zerstörung
ein ein
man sieht dass die Leichen nicht
einfach so diese Welt verlassen die
waren gequält und hingerichtet und das
war
sehr sehr
außergewöhnlich nicht maßgeblich
kriegt man diese Bilder das frage ich
mich immer wenn man das mal so gesehen
hat stumpft man da ab kriegt man das
jemals wieder aus dem Kopf träumt man
nachts davon wie geht's anders
ich glaube dass die Bilder nicht nur bei
denjenigen die das
tagtäglich noch immer erleben Ukraine
die Bilder dank Medien dank
den beobachtet den Journalisten den Mut
haben eine Frontlinie zu sein dort wo
das
grausame gerade passiert wir
dokumentiert und die Bilder sollte im
Haag dann später als als
Nachfolge den Taten als Konsequenz
gesehen werden das wird auch gemacht das
verstehen wir das wissen wir wir wissen
nicht nur wann und
es muss bestraft werden das ist nie
wieder passiert das nie wieder haben wir
schon mal gehört nach zwei Jahren leider
passiert das in so ein riesen
europäischen Land wie die Ukraine schon
mal wieder und es zu sein dass die
Menschheit hat nichts davon gelernt von
der Vergangenheit von erstens Zweiten
Weltkrieg also wir reden gerade nicht
über Weltkrieg aber wir reden gerade
über einen Krieg und Europa in Ukraine
einer der größten Länder ja das größte
Flächenland Europas
ich habe es eben gerade schon gesagt und
das ist nur eine ganz ein ganz kleiner
Ausschnitt Frau korkers in Odessa damals
gesehen
die Menschen sind grau die gehen gebeugt
die sind belastet da gibt es dieses
Misstrauen überall wenn man irgendwo
anhält dann an einer Kreuzung zum
Beispiel ein Foto macht dann würde
jemand in Hamburg oder in Berlin sagen
seit die Touristen wo kommt die her und
was fotografiert ihr gerade was
interessiert euch gerade in nur deshalb
bist du gefragt bist du ein russischer
Agent und identifizierst du vielleicht
gerade irgendein Ziel das heißt der
frisst sich so ein Misstrauen in die
Gesellschaft rein haben Sie das auch
beobachtet was machen so 500 Tage kriegt
was machen die mit einer Gesellschaft
also ich muss sagen vor einem Tier
beobachte ich genau das Gegenteil dessen
dass sie gerade schildern die Leute
leben noch mal intensiver als zuvor auch
wenn diese Krieg an allen nagt das
Schlafanzug das ist die Sorge um
Familienmitglieder die immer noch in
besetzten Gebieten leben aber trotzdem
ja trotzdem sieht man diese vor allem im
Sommer auch noch mal diese Lebensmittel
meine Situation
sehr vielen Menschen zu schaffen gemacht
haben aber auch ich falls vor kurzem in
Odessa ich glaube vor drei Wochen da
habe ich das nicht so gesehen ich glaube
das war es wahrscheinlich auch eine
Momentaufnahme im Winter aber je näher
man an die Front kommt und auch wenn man
ihn wieder befreite Gebiete kommt
beobachtet man genau das und vor allem
in Gebieten die monatelang unter
Besatzung waren ist eine normales Leben
nicht möglich weil die Menschen einander
Misstrauen weil die Nachbarn sich
gegenseitig verraten haben und man im
Endeffekt am Schluss auch alleine steht
also auch Leute die fliehen aus diesen
besetzten Gebieten sagen sie konnten am
Schluss nicht mal den eigenen
Familienmitgliedern Vertrauen und das
ist etwas ganz Schreckliches als
Menschen leben wir zusammen das ist
unsere Natur und das wird diesen
Menschen genommen genau eine
Gesellschaft Wladimir lebt von Vertrauen
also wie hat sich aus ihrer sich diese
ukrainische Gesellschaft verändert
enorm das heißt ich immer verändert auch
einfach interessant meine eigene
Beobachtung ich sehe die Bilder in Kiez
zum Beispiel
[Musik]
von einer Gesellschaft man sieht in den
Augen im Gesicht wenn man Menschen das
ist vor dem Krieg gedreht worden
heute erkennt man
dass die Augen und Gesichter strahlen
was anderes ich kann das nie genau
erzählen woran das liegt aber aber es
ist ganz klar zu sehen die Bilder davor
und die Bilder jetzt und es ist richtig
gesagt worden dass das Leben kann man
nicht stoppen man Gebühren sie dran man
man adaptiert sich man liebt das Leben
geht zu die Arbeit am Tag und nachts
werden dann die Kameras Drohne fliegen
und das passierte dann tagtäglich im in
diesem Jahr seit dem Frühling und es ist
wenn nicht den in Kiel dann ist es
irgendwo in der Ukraine aber das am Tag
sag mal so das Leben wird ziemlich
normal und nachts hört man Explosion
also entweder ihn oder Autos das heißt
oder genau oder dann wird man getroffen
irgendwo also man und kann schon
unterscheiden die die Geräusche also was
ist das ist das was angekommen oder ist
das abgeschossen worden auf jeden Fall
man sieht auch das Leben in den großen
Städten wie Neapel wie karikife weniger
ja das ist Geisterstadt also ja sieht
noch normal aus aber man sieht da fast
kaum Menschen und kaum Fahrzeuge in die
Pro ist es mir oder weniger was auch nie
so weit von der Frontlinie das Leben
wirkt okay aber im Süden und Osten des
Landes der sieht man einfach keine
Zivilisten mehr und das sind nur Militär
Leute und haben so wir haben zu man
sieht doch die Zivilisten und
Jugendliche oder Kinder das überrascht
hat einfach und man denkt was haben die
denn da zu suchen weil er es ist einfach
einfach enorm gefährlich aber es gibt
unterschiedliche Geschichten von von
Familien die halt nicht die Möglichkeit
haben nicht das Fahrzeug haben nicht
rechtzeitig geschafft haben zu fliehen
und die adaptieren sich zu einem Leben
wenn man das Leben nennen kann genau
wahnsinn das heißt ich nehme dem sie
sind selber auch häufiger an der Front
an der Frontlinie ich ich war eine
freundlinie es ist auch in
vor kurzem vor kurzem ist mit sehr 300
konstantinowska getroffen worden direkt
an der Stadt also es ist eine an der
Frontlinie
russische
[Musik]
treu schon mal davor konnte noch es
erreichen aber das mit sehr 300 es war
schrecklich dass direkt im heiligen Tag
wo die Menschen dann
unterwegs sind
es ist schon wirklich
unterschiedliche Welten also in einem
Land während des Krieges und dass man so
im Westen sei mal so das Leben irgendwie
mehr oder weniger was auch wieder
abgeschossen also
Raketen die Stadt getroffen haben im
Westen der Ukraine und man sieht einfach
wenn du in der Ukraine bist
es gibt keine Sicherheit dass du dass du
am Leben bleibst oder gesund bleibst
weil weil in jedem Moment
entweder am Tag oder meistens dann
nachts wird wir dann jede Stadt
beschossen deswegen habe ich diesen
Respekt für die Journalisten und die
Menschen die sich
entscheiden die Krim zu unterstützen und
um eigene Bild zu schaffen und ich weiß
dass das du unterwegs bist in der
umkretung gewesen und im nächsten auch
sein wirst ich weiß dass sie werden auch
wieder zurückkehren und
diese Unterstützung vor allem nicht nur
auf der Distanz sondern sondern da zu
sein man schafft ein ganz andere Bild
eigenes Bild wenn weil diese Fan
Diagnose ist ist von Zeitungen und
Fernsehen das ist was anderes als wenn
man selbst unterwegs ist dann kann man
sich besseren besseren Bild schaffen und
auch Verständnis was gebraucht wird
gerade über die Art und Weise gesprochen
wie man sich daran gewöhnt was ich so
eindrucksvoll fand waren die Bilder aus
Butcher es gibt dieses ikonographische
fürchterliche Foto da können wir das
einmal kurz zeigen dieser einen Straße
die übersät war mit diesem ganzen Toten
gefolterten und verschlichtung
ergreifend ermordeten Menschen das ist
ein Bild davon und wenn man diese selbe
Straße sich wenige Monate später
anschaut dann sieht die so aus das heißt
alles wieder hergestellt repariert in
kürzester Zeit mein Eindruck war auch in
Odessa dass die Ukraine unglaublich
darum bemüht sind mit großer
Geschwindigkeit so schnell wie möglich
alles wieder herzustellen damit auch
psychologisch nichts zu sehen ist was
die Leute verstört stimmt das stimmt
man baut ganz schnell um oder stelle es
wieder wenn es möglich ist aber das ist
dieselbe Straße zerstört das was man
nicht wieder herstellen kann also
reparieren kann oder wieder aufbauen
kann um das neu zu bauen oder das alte
zu reparieren das stimmt weil wie gesagt
das Leben kann man nicht stoppen und ich
glaube diesen Krieg anzufangen man muss
ihre sein
weil
es wird kein kein Sieg für Russland in
diesem sinnlosen Krieg geben es wird
kein Krieg es wird
deswegen
wir verstehen dass es einbekommt nur je
mehr grauen Taten werden gemacht
ist einfach nur
wobei
wenn ich kurz einhaken darf Butter da
will natürlich auch jeder Geld
hinschicken um das wieder aufzubauen bei
guter einfach so ein symbolischer Ort
auch geworden ist in diesem Krieg das
heißt sehr viele internationale Gelder
gingen auch nach guter und es war dann
möglich so schnell Butter wieder
aufzubauen was natürlich toll ist da
können Kinder wieder Kindergärten gehen
und so weiter aber die das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung in der Ukraine ist so groß
und der wird so viel Geld nötig sein und
an vielen Orten sieht man eben solche
Bilder noch nicht die sind zerstört die
bleiben zerstört und es wird Jahre
dauern und Jahrzehnte das wieder
aufzubauen alles und auch sehr viele
Geld und auch Unterstützung aus dem
Westen
trotzdem unheimlich beeindruckend ne
weil
da auch die Psychologie dahinter ganz
offenbar eine große große Rolle spielt
ich habe dieser Tage der der Chef der
Eisenbahn der ukrainischen ist eine
Einheiten Status in der Ukraine weil das
bis jetzt glaube ich schafft die
Eisenbahn ziemlich pünktlich fahren zu
lassen ist an den logistisches
Meisterwerk und der sagte wir waren sehr
sehr gut darin die Dinge zu reparieren
schon in der Vergangenheit als der Krieg
kam waren wir fantastisch und
mittlerweile haben wir die Dinge schon
repariert bevor die Russen sie überhaupt
zerstört haben also als als Scherz
gemeint das heißt die Ukrainer würden
Sie sagen Frau kortas sind was die Moral
angeht kein gebrochenes Volk
nee wirklich nicht und ich mag manchmal
den Eindruck dass man in Deutschland
darauf wartet dass irgendjemand mal sagt
boah die haben keine Lust mehr die sind
fertig aber sind sie nicht denn es gibt
keine andere Möglichkeit wenn man als
ukrainischer Mensch dort lebt vielleicht
auch wirklich Familie hat in besetzten
Gebieten wie vorhin schon gesagt ähm
dort seine Familie aufgebaut hat sich
als Ukrainerin Ukraine versteht was ist
die Alternative zu sagen okay jetzt
gehen wir auf und dann gucken wir mal
wie weit die Lust noch kommen also es
gab ja als junges ein Propaganda Video
äh wieder der russischen Seite das noch
mal bewiesen hat dass ich die
Kriegsziele seit und jetzt nicht
verändert haben und das ist die
Zerstörung der Nation und auch die
Stützung der Regierung und das wird sich
nicht ändern und so lange müssen die
Ukraine und du keine stark bleiben wenn
sie dann dort leben wollen und dieses
Land haben wollen und hier Nationen
nicht zerstörten ausgelöst sehen wollen
weil sie das gerade sagen und wir haben
vorhin vielleicht können wir das nochmal
zeigen dieses eine Bild gesehen wo du
lass uns beim dubleiben bleiben wir ja
wir kennen uns schon ein paar Tage
normalerweise sieht man sich im
Fernsehen aber du sagtest gerade du das
ist völlig in Ordnung du bist darauf zu
sehen mit deinem Bruder Vitali und man
sieht auf diesem Foto du hast wenig
geschlafen du bist wichtig angefasst von
dem was da passiert ist wie erinnerst Du
diesen ersten Moment diesen 24 februar
ist deutet sich über Wochen an da
passiert etwas die haben irgendetwas vor
die Amerikaner die Geheimdienste sagen
die werden es machen wir glauben bis zum
Schluss vielleicht gibt's da noch einen
Ausweg sie werden es nicht tun ich habe
ihn Gesprächen in der Ukraine
mitgekriegt die Ukraine haben Sie
eigentlich nie eine Illusion darüber
gemacht was sie tatsächlich vorhatten
die wussten dass das passieren wird dann
passiert es tatsächlich die kommen rein
es geht um Kiew und dann erfährt man
dass man selber auf einer Todesliste
steht zum Beispiel von caddierung dem
Staatschef aus Tschetschenien und du
weißt diese Leute üble Leute sind hinter
dir ganz persönlich her was ist das für
ein Gefühl
wir haben davon angefangen zu reden man
gewöhnen sich daran
man hat damit nicht gerechnet
ich bin
ich bin froh dass ich nirgendwo im
Ausland war sondern in Kiefer
am 24.02
du hast gerade während
es ist klar gesagt worden es gibt drei
Stufen
frag deine Sachen zusammen
sei bereit und jetzt los also das Land
verlassen weil der kriegt wird
kommt
und genau diese drei Stufen und die
Vorwarnungen ganz klar waren und ganz
klar bewusst die Antwort war auf keinen
Fall los reden sondern bleiben es ist
ich weiß noch wahrscheinlich es gibt
viele viele viele Geschichten und viele
Bilder und aber was was ganz
außergewöhnlich war Stadt Kiel
seine lebende Stadt ja also man lebt
dort 24 7
Tag und Nacht es ist eine internationale
Stadt und plötzlich
ist es eine Geisterstadt die
straßenmeile es gab keine Menschen am
Tag in der Nacht weil
weil die stürmische Streitkräfte waren
waren
im Angriff und und direkt am Stadtrand
und es war wirklich also die Bilder
diese Bilder das Leben auf einmal hat
die Stadt verlassen und das war das war
sehr sehr im negativen Sinne
beeindruckend weil man konnte sich das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen es sind Staus
das ist also das ist einfach Menschen wo
sind die denn auf einmal
eine komplette Geisterstadt geworden
aber man hat schon gesehen die nächste
Bilder das sind doch die die Menschen
die in geblieben sind und Schlangen
Schlangen von Menschen standen um die
Waffe zu bekommen weil die Waffen sind
verteilt worden man sollte dann mit
Wasser rüberkommen und und dann hätte
man einen AK inside gedrückt bekommen um
die Stadt zu verteidigen weil man sich
für die Straßenkämpfe vorbereitet
mit Sandsäcken und Fenstern und
da standen Männer alte Männer sehr alte
Männer Frauen sehr alte Frauen also es
gab es gab einfach keinen kein Bild also
oder kein Bild wo man dann sagt ja also
der kann kämpfen oder nicht sondern
schon wirklich ob der alte ob man fühlt
oder oder sportlich oder gar nicht man
einfach
man stand dafür die Stadt zu verteidigen
und das stimmt auch die Pläne sind nicht
anders geworden und die haben sich nicht
verändert
putin wird weiter angreifen und wird
weiter provozieren und wird weiter seine
Pläne um um dieses sowjetische Imperium
sowjetischen Reich wieder darzustellen
und wenn die Ukraine fällt was nicht
passieren wird
wir werden nicht die ersten die die
letzten sein das Appetit von den
russischen Propaganda sieht man auch es
ist deutlich dass die baltische Länder
als nächstes das Polen als nächste Land
sein wird also das sowjetische reich und
diese Ambition diese Kranken Beziehung
stehen nach wie vor da
wenn du sagst mal hätte eine AK 47
die Hand bekommen
wärst du bereit du musst doch damit
rechnen Männer bis 60 und du bist noch
nicht 60 einberufen zu werden an die
Front zu müssen könnt ihr das passieren
jede der unter 60 ist denn der Ukraine
ist steht in der Pflicht und es gibt
unterschiedliche Stufen der
Mobilisierung und man ist verpflichtet
den Land zu dienen und an verschiedene
Seiten nicht alle sollten und müssen an
der Front sein es gibt unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche Stufen waren und wie
und wer und wir wir verlieren leider
unsere unsere beste Leute das sind
Männer und Frauen eine Front und man
muss dann wieder
die Arme auffüllen sozusagen und diese
Unterstützung kaufen und das geht dann
um die Mobilisierung und natürlich jede
vor allem auch Mann ist verpflichtet an
die Front wurde damit zu rechnen aber
gewissen Zeitpunkt auch mit den Waffen
denn
ich habe schon diese Frage bekommen du
bist nicht der Erste der mich gefragt
hat vor allem auch vor allem auch ich
warte auf die nächste Frage und das ist
mehr wichtiger ich bin nicht bereit ich
war schon eine Front und
um die Eindrücke zu schaffen
entweder Stadt Kiew am Anfang des
Krieges wo ist wo ist das Front gewesen
oder im Südosten der Ukraine aber die
Frage die man dann wieder gesagt wird
und das ist der Unterschied zwischen
Russen und dem Ukraine
bist du bereit für dein Land zu sterben
die Frage ist mir aufgestellt worden
also wenn du schon mit AK in oder welche
auch immer war im Hand hast und seine
Freund gerufen ist desto Unterschied
zwischen russischen ukrainischen
Soldaten
nein ich bin nicht bereit für das Land
zu sterben ich bin bereit für das Land
zu leben das ist eher komplizierter als
sterben man hört schon die Geschichten
und ich habe selbst gehört dass in
enormen Zahlen russische Soldaten die
die nach vorne reden mit Waffen oder
sogar ohne Waffen werden fallen werden
gekillt und dann kommen die neuen und
neuen in solche Wellen und wieder und
wieder und ich glaube schon dass wenn
man versteht dann diesen Sklaven gefühlt
und wie die behandelt werden
mobilisiert werden wie die dann
hingeschmissen werden
Ukraine interessant sind sind anders wir
sind frei Menschen und Menschen die eine
Front sind sind nicht mobilisiert in die
Mehrheit des Menschen die freiwillig
sich entschieden haben und davon zu
gehen also das ist der Unterschied also
wenn du es
machen muss wie das
meistens oder von russischer Seite ist
und derjenige der dann als Frau Mann
sich und eigene zu Hause verteidigt und
eigene Familie und eigene Stadt eigenes
Land dann ist schon mental ein ganz ganz
anderes Bild man darf nicht
unterschätzen dass die Menge natürlich
ein riesen Unterschied macht der
russischen und der ukrainische mehr also
wir wir sind wie sind wir wollen leben
für das Land und deswegen suchen wir
jede andere Möglichkeit denn Gegner
also dass wir dann mit schlaue Waffen
und einfach besser vorankommen auch in
diese Offensive vor Gott dass die Frage
ist wie lange kann man das Durchhalten
ne ich habe es gibt keine verlässlichen
Zahlen ne weder Kiew noch Moskau gibt
belastbare Zahlen raus die Ukraine
braucht jedes Jahr um diesen Krieg
durchzuhalten zwischen 300 und 400.000
frischen Männern
das kann man lange durchhalten als als
Land mit 35 36 Millionen Einwohnern
sechs Millionen Ukrainer sind nicht mehr
im eigenen Land
das heißt der hat schon eine Schwächung
dieses Landes eine massive Schwächung
stattgefunden und insofern geht er auch
so ein Plan von Putin auf einer gewisse
Art und Weise auf aber du brauchst jedes
Jahr wenn dieser Krieg weitergeht 3
400.000 Leute und das Holz und sich die
die Berichte davon dass Männer sich auch
versuchen zu entziehen
es gab mal vor Beginn dieser
Gegenoffensive
eine verstärkte Mobilisierung das fand
auch im Westen des Landes statt und
damals war das ein riesiges Thema in
Ukraine weil auch vor Supermärkten oder
enzügen oder einfach auf der Straße
mobilisiert wurde und die Menschen die
kämpfen wollten freiwillig kämpfen
wollten die sind schon anders schon das
heißt es ist klar es gibt immer wieder
mal Leute die ausgesetzten Gebieten
fliehen oder oder denen es anderweitig
gelegt wieder ins Land zurückzukommen
die dann auch von sich selbst Aussagen
sie wollen kämpfen oder es ist irgendwas
Schreckliches passiert in der Familie
die sagen jetzt aber muss ich kämpfen
gehen solche Männer gibt es auch aber ja
in der Mehrheit ähm sind die Männer die
jetzt für die nächsten kommenden
offensiven mobilisiert werden die werden
meistens auch angesprochen ja also ich
glaube es ist völlig normal dass in
einer Gesellschaft nicht jeder an die
Front gehen möchte ich habe auch sehr
viele kluge Köpfe beispielsweise in Kiew
getroffen die Ingenieur sind die an
diesen neuen Drohnen Bast handeln und
die entwickeln und die auch gesagt haben
naja was will ich Lauch an der Front ich
kann nicht kämpfen aber ich kann
Waffensystem entwickeln die den Leuten
an der Front helfen also ich glaube man
kann das das ist nicht schwarz-weiß aber
klar Menschen Männer Soldaten
Soldatinnen das ist etwas das der Westen
nicht zur Verfügung stellen will und
kann
weil ja es ist klar die Nato will nicht
in diesen Krieg eintreten und was die
Ukraine jetzt machen und die
Ukrainerinnen das die versuchen ihre
Soldaten und Soldatinnen so sicher wie
möglich zu halten beispielsweise in
diesem dunklenkrieg ja also man
entwickelt jetzt sogenannte ground
stations das sind Stationen von denen
aus man in relativer Sicherheit auch
unter unter der Erde Drohnen steuern
kann und so weiter und diese Krieg
entwickelt sich so ein bisschen mehr in
diesen Krieg 2.0 also ein Historiker und
Ukraine sagte das ist Erste Weltkrieg +
Drohnen und diese Drohnen nehmen eine
immer größere ein ja also das ist auch
auf russische Seite die gucken sich das
ab wir leben in der Zeit wo sehr viele
Kameras auch an der Front
einfach jeder ein Handy hat und sehr
viele Kameras an der Front Fotos
aufnehmen und Videos aufnehmen aber das
ist gerade die Entwicklung die wir
machen man versucht auf ukrainische
Seite sehr bewusst so wenige Soldaten
und Soldaten möglich ja so opfern oder
oder sterben zu sehen verletzt zu sehen
was aber wirklich eine Herausforderung
ist gibt dir diese großen riesigen
Minenfelder wie wir alle haben jetzt
auch gehört haben die einfach in
Sekunden einem Mann das Bein oder das
Leben nehmen können und auch da versucht
man zum Beispiel Drohnen zu entwickeln
die Felder entminen aber das ist
wirklich sehr schwierig und es dauert
und dafür braucht man auch Gelder und so
weiter aber ja klar Russland spielt auf
Zeit denn die haben einfach mehr
Menschen
mobilisieren
wie wie die Ukraine und das ist
natürlich eine Schwierigkeit das heißt
für die Ukraine es ist wirklich wichtig
jetzt auch
Waffensysteme zu erhalten die
Versorgungswege der Russen ja
beschädigen können aushalten können und
sie schneller das passiert dass du
besser für die Ukraine